The right answers are the first two boxes here. And
let's talk through this. Now clearly, if we want to
do anything in the router, we need buy in from
the router vendors. So this is a big challenge and
convincing the router makers that, yes please open up the
network so that I can dump some code in it
and execute. The code, so that is a big challenge.
The second is also a big challenge and that is,
if you look at the traffic on the internet
today it's just humongous. There's so much traffic on
the internet, and this is the reason why routers
are dumb animals. All that the do is when a
packet comes in, it's all happening in hardware, they
do a table look up to figure out. Given the
destination, what is the next stop that I send
this package to? So the internet core, the routing fabric
is operating at huge speeds, because even at the
edge of the network today, we are already seeing gigabit
speeds. Which means that the core of the network, you
have several hundreds of gigabytes of packet processing that needs
to be done and therefore it is important that
the core of the network be blazingly fast. And software
routing is not going to be able to match the speed
that is needed in the core of the network for
packet processing. So these two choices are good
choices. Now, does active network's make the Internet
more vulnerable? Not really because the internet is
already vulnerable. Perhaps, it adds to it but not
particularly making it more vulnerable than what it
is already. And the last choice regarding code spoofing,
so long as we make sure that the
fingerprint that we generate to associate with the code,
that is going to be used for processing the capsule when it
arrives at a node. Is, cryptographically strong, then we can make
sure that this code spoofing does not happen, so I would
say, these are the two choices that apply for this question.